[Music]
cat is with us in pittsburgh hey kat
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave how are you today thank you for
having me my honor what's
up um yes i just wanted to give you a
little bit of background about me um
i'm married
currently we just got mark and i just
got married on may 7th
and um we are currently debt free
thanks lord
and
we have
approximately
about 70 to 80 k in liquid
and we make collectively right around 70
to 75
yearly and what we are doing right now
is we're renting an apartment
so with our rental
um rent utilities our expenses are right
around 850 to 900 a month
and right now uh we do have some crypto
investments and we'd really like to get
into retail um i'm sorry real estate
investment as well
but we're not sure if maybe either
moving into a duplex for our first home
would be the right choice as far as
making
um you know having a place to move into
and obviously making some investment on
the other side of that duplex
or if maybe we should like buy a smaller
home fix it up and within a year's time
maybe move out of that to another one
and then just rent that home out or flip
it
but that's what we want to ask you okay
well i think a a precursor to the answer
is uh the rule that we use at ramsey is
we give you we answer your questions of
what we would do
knowing what we know
if we woke up in your shoes
okay
and uh i by the time i started with
nothing and by the time i was 26 i
bought four million dollars worth of
real estate
i was doing flip this house before chip
and joanna were born
literally i mean i'm not kidding
it was early 80s right and um no
disrespect to them because they're
wonderful
but the uh um
you know and i
i was using short-term notes to borrow
money to flip the house and make a
profit i made a profit on almost every
deal i did
and i still went broke
because the bank got nervous and called
all our notes at one time and there's a
word we use for real estate that sells
really fast
cheap
so we end up selling the real estate for
less than it was owed on it which was
way less than it was worth to keep
foreclosures from happening and it broke
me and i lost everything in my 20s
okay so that's who's answering your
question i by the way do love real
estate i own several hundred million
dollars worth of real estate today
but after that i quit borrowing money
and so that's the guy and the place that
you called to get your question answered
you need to know that it's in fairness
okay so if you wanted to flip this house
with money
uh borrowed money
and all that kind of stuff you're really
on the wrong show you're not going to do
what we tell you to do
okay so having said all that uh
you know here's my answer on duplexes as
your first property
and then here's my answer what we would
do if we woke up in your shoes
the beautiful thing about a duplex is
your renter lives next door
the problem with the duplex is your
renter lives next door
can you tell i've been there okay
so if they want something they can knock
on your door but you also don't have
much trouble collecting the rent because
they're right there cars in the driveway
you know and so we're going to get our
money we don't have to wait on some
thing to happen and so it's a you have
to set some relational emotional
boundaries if you're going to do that
that's the problem it's not that bad
the biggest issue i had with duplexes
and i've owned i don't know
probably a hundred of them
is that the uh
typically are rental properties
and so typically the buyer when you get
ready to resell them is another investor
who's looking for a deal
the buyer when you get ready to sell
that same square footage of house as a
duplex in a single family is a cute
little couple that wants a picket fence
and a place for their french bulldog to
run around
it feels like a personal attack yeah it
was a personal attack george just take
it for what it is and
they're willing to pay more like retail
and so single-family homes of the same
square footage within a two-block area
will go up faster in value than duplexes
will because of who your pool of buyer
future buyers are in general
now a nice duplex will outperform a
lousy single family neighborhood i'm not
talking about it i'm talking about
apples to apples comparison okay
so if you could find a really cool
duplex in an up-and-coming sweet
re-gentrified neighborhood might be a
real seriously good play right versus
buying a dumpy single family okay so
that that's your upsides and downsides
on duplexes what would i do if i woke up
in your shoes and george i'll let you
chime in after the personal attack but
the uh
is i would pay cash for my first home as
soon as i can and you're very close to
doing that once you have decided you
don't like losing 50 of your money in
bitcoin
and so um how much do you guys have in
crypto just curious
um well since we just got married we
haven't merged all that yet i really
don't know how much he has i have
approximately just shy of 10 grand okay
okay
you guys are
much
you like risk more than i do but i've
been broke
that's another thing you need to keep in
mind i i don't like risk much i don't
like losing money i lost a bunch of it
and it's too hard to make i don't like
losing it
so and and i know that because you're
playing with um lottery money over there
kryptos
you know you've lost your butt on it
and um and i'll stand around acting like
you did something cool you know it's
just it's it's it's horrible so i'd be
getting out of that i'd be buying some
real estate i paid cash for it george
yeah i mean you guys don't have a home
currently right primary residence right
that would be my first goal i wouldn't
mess with the duplex and plus they're
really hard to find right now because
you're not the only one who had this
awesome idea and so if i'm you i'm
getting into a primary residence with
the money you have put a strong down
payment down work on paying that off as
soon as possible and then man the world
is your oyster
paycheck what i did after i went bro cat
was i got my house paid off
took me a little while
then i saved up i paid cash for my first
rental
not the sexiest answer though and they
don't you know what happened you know
what happens with a rental that you have
zero debt on it cash flows like a bandit
it starts just stacking money up and i'm
able to pay cash for the second one
fairly quick
and you got two of them sitting there
with zero payments
you're just stacking money
and you can buy the third one then
you're just stacking money
and ever since then i've been just
stacking money
and then i have some idiot walk up to me
and go you're so lucky luck didn't have
squat to do with it duber
i used a system and a process you know
but dave the renter is going to pay my
mortgage no they don't because don't
always pay
can you say pandemic
can you say
eviction moratorium
yeah yeah
yeah you can't get them out and you know
what i had some people that were had
some serious problems during coven and i
could be gentle as a landlord
because you don't need the money because
i didn't have to have the money to eat
you know i have one had cancer
i don't throw somebody's got cancer in
the street i'm not heartless
now you know you beat your wife and you
don't pay your bills i'll put your crap
in the street
but you know but the thing is
you know you can be gentle when you
don't have any payments and changes
their whole world cat it takes a little
longer
but i've done detailed research and 100
of the foreclosures occur on a home with
a mortgage